we may need to hire a new i.t director
why don't you and gina get together on
that i doubt i'll need gina's help i'm
sure she's busy anyway
use gina she's my assistant and she has
something to offer
trust me
and i'll be hacking into my stuff
nah you must be simon walker have a seat
it says here you were an i.t specialist
with the board event for 10 years well i
know my way around a computer that's for
sure query what's your favorite jay-z
song
i'm sorry favorite jay-z song
she's kidding
no i'm not what is it i don't know i'm
sorry about her
what's your experience with cyber
security uh well i added uh encryption
software seriously what's your favorite
jesus i don't know big pippin it's big
pimpin
wrong answer friend
and that's um how i got involved in
you know systems analysis
i'm sorry i'm really nervous there's no
need to be nervous
yeah we're all just calm cool collected
oops was that a little
sudden
what would you say is your biggest
weakness as an employee um
i'm sorry what was the question again he
said
what's your biggest weakness as an
employee that's just gross i'm sorry i
just have a scooch of gingivitis so i'm
trying to treat that as best i can sorry
you seem disgusting so of all the
candidates that you interviewed today
who do you think i should hire well the
interviews got a little off try but i'd
go with simon walker computer science
degree worked for the board of ed for 10
years that guy no way he yelled at me
when i asked him the same question about
jay-z three times in a row why does that
matter because whoever takes this i.t
job is gonna have to deal with hitchcock
asking how to log into his email every
single day forever how do you think
professor short fuse is gonna handle
that fine what about this guy
no he was scared of everything do you
remember rosa's reaction last time the
printer jammed
i'll pay for that
fine
what was with the flossing um a precinct
is a pretty gross place terra bear
there's blood wounds scully's feet you
need a strong stomach and that lady did
not have one plus we already have the
perfect candidate already savant
that punk who hacked us precisely
turn your greatest weakness into your
greatest strength like paris hilton read
her sex tape get to the point savant
tore our walls down but he can build
them back up
taller and thicker than ever but how can
we be sure he won't turn on us his mom
ratted him out so i bet he'd love a
steady paycheck to get out of that
snitch's house
buy a mic right now
i drop it
there we have it children your problem
is not that you're troubled or at risk
or bad dressers is that trucker hat
still come on
your problem is that you don't have
passion for anything
my life
turned around when i found my passion
and today well i hope to inspire you
with it
[Music]
you are beautiful
no matter what they say
words can't bring you
down
[Music]
what are we thinking
yes in the denim i think i speak for
everyone when i say your weird dancing
was just weird fine
cops make 52 000 a year you never have
to stop at a red light and you get to
carry a gun who wants in
boom boom boom boom yes
oh my god you got eight kids to sign up
how did you know that would work that's
what made me sign up when i was a kid
you did this program mm-hmm yeah it does
not work
detectives i see we got eight recruits
for the junior police program
outstanding thank you sir but as
important as your praise is to me it
should actually go to gina she's the one
that got through to the kids yes i am
amazing and i only asked for one thing
in repayment
a 600 raise or i could give you a zero
percent raise and make you my personal
assistant which is what i'm doing i
think you have hidden talents which will
make you surprisingly good at the job no
i have no talents you start monday
ugh
constantly getting hulk's approval is
the worst yes i can only imagine it's no
secret the nypd has an image problem
yeah when i told my garbage man i was a
cop he said gross
he had someone else's band-aid stuck to
him police approval ratings are part of
my language in the commode
all the headlines are about the bad cops
but they're good cops too and i want to
put up posters that showcase some of our
best i'd like you to be on the first one
shut up ray
i mean
interesting captain i'll think about it
wow this is a bad idea first off amy has
an epic lack of swagger uh i'll have you
know i have swagger i ooze
swagger
right more importantly putting up a
bunch of photos of smiling cops isn't
gonna change how people feel about us i
think this campaign is very promising
santiago what's your take oh right let's
hear an unbiased opinion from your
straight-up swim fan
i think it's a great idea sir
well you can count me out i will not
pose for your posters i didn't ask you
and you're not a police officer yeah
i'm out
sir i saw my poster on the subway this
morning well you must feel like a
celebrity a regular ira glass
they put a hitler mustache on me
yes this is unfortunate
but let's not overreact to one graffito
it wasn't just one
people drew on every single poster
they put double horns
target on my face this one says die pig
and worst of all they didn't put the
comma between dye and pig this is easily
dealt with i'll just issue a statement
saying vandals will be prosecuted it's
not just vandalism sir people have real
complaints too
end stop and frisk stop racial profiling
unlawful arrest is a crime
why is it i think gina was right about
the campaign sir
i'm surprised she hasn't marched in here
to say i told you so she wouldn't do
that you're right amy
for once in your life you're 100 right i
would never say that
did you have enough time to read at all
yes
okay good
gina as you predicted there was some
backlash to the poster campaign yes i'm
the nostradamus of your shame i think a
problem the police have had is our
inability to admit our mistakes so
this campaign
was
um
a mistake you told me that but i got
defensive and didn't listen i should
have been open to criticism as this
department should be open to criticism
that's why i'm replacing these
with
these
my email address is at the bottom and i
intend to respond to every message i
receive before we put them up i want to
hear your thoughts
i love them
once again my advice has like saved the
city i came up with the slogan it's
tacky to take credit for stuff
no you're the fool
hey little man why is that teeny i'm not
teeny i'm average size
what a sad brag i don't even know who
you are but i know who you are devin you
tell everyone you got a degree from
stanford but you really went to stam
forbe an online college based in
arkansas
it's a good school you live with your
aunt that's sad and you spend a third of
your salary on tropical fish and
aquarius
you know i found all this off of
20 minutes of idol snooping around
imagine what i could do with a dedicated
couple of hours what do you want i want
you to give the internet back to my
friends
okay we're all keep digging and digging
and digging and digging fine fine i'll
give you back your internet okay just
we're through oh and maybe your
co-workers would like to know what
happened on your seventh grade field
trip to d.c you monster he pooped in the
reflecting pool
if i could have your attention please
i'm being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately what the
hell i don't understand what the hell
why are you doing this what the hell
i want to say
it has been a pleasure to have worked
alongside all of you for the past 21 and
a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best
years of my career oh no this is new
and i know that
every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more
see
dismissed
sir
i'm coming with you thank you gina i'm
also coming not necessary
you